- "Moderate beer consumption
"lowers your risk of heart
attack by 25 to 40," lies!
Instagram has some controversial
medical information on it,
but Facebook is known to be the
home to medical conspiracies
so let's check out these health posts,
and give a huge thank you to Thrive Market
for sponsoring this video
and these sweet potato chips.
(loud crunch)
Wee woo!
"The best breakfast for you
based on your zodiac sign."
(laughs)
This is a meme, right?
Like this is not a Facebook health post.
A Gemini should eat raisin bran?
A Leo, it looks like a
wrap from Dunkin Donuts.
This is absolutely ridonkulous.
"Health benefits of dance.
"Boost memory, improve
flexibility, reduce stress,
"increase anxiety, improve
balance and posture."
(hip hop music)
(grunts)
Okay look.
Is dance gonna boost your memory?
Probably not.
Is it gonna improve flexibility?
Probably 'cause you gotta
keep your hips moving.
Any time you got through
a wide range of motion,
you're gonna improve flexibility.
Are you gonna reduce stress?
Yeah, 'cause it's awesome to dance.
Are you gonna increase energy?
Yeah, because you're exercising.
Are you gonna improve balance and posture?
Yeah, 'cause look at these moves.
(beeps)
(imitates cat)
I actually took some dance classes
at the beginning of this year
and they got shut down 'cause of COVID.
My dance moves are awful because of COVID
and I'm sticking with that statement.
"How to calm a crying baby in
one minute," ooh I like this.
"These pressure points
will help to relax them."
(lively music)
I'm scared where this is going.
Head and teeth.
(lively music)
Wait, wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It says, "Head/Teeth,"
and then they're pressing
on the baby's toes.
I don't know what's
going on in this video,
it already seems highly inaccurate.
Chest, and then the foot lights up.
Wait, I'm so confused.
Don't listen to this.
If a baby's crying, A,
you need to figure out
what could be going wrong.
Are they hungry, have they wet themselves,
is there a part of their
body that's bothering them,
and if you've checked all those things
and you think your baby's all right,
you should really try
and move the baby around.
I wanna tell you about my
long partner, Thrive Market.
It's an online marketplace
that makes healthy eating and
healthy shopping affordable.
They have 25 to 50% off retail prices.
They have home goods,
beauty products, food.
What I love is when you
go on their website,
you can actually sort it by the things
that are important to you.
Values, diet, for example,
if you're following Keto,
click Keto, Paleo, Paleo,
cruelty-free it's there.
And during COVID, it's really convenient
to have all these things
delivered right to your home.
I've used it for a really long time
and I've been recommending
it for you guys as well.
There's all sorts of membership options.
For me, the 12 month package at $5 a month
is the no-brainer to select.
They have a money back guarantee option
and their warehouses are zero waste.
So it's not only good for you,
it's also good for the environment.
"You can run on one!
"Some people are born with just one kidney
"and live healthy lives."
Can you live with one kidney?
Absolutely.
In fact I know people
who have donated a kidney
to their loved one or a compatible match.
Hold on, I believe Selena Gomez received
a kidney from one of her friends,
but you have to take really cautious steps
once you only have one kidney.
You really need to make
sure you're well-hydrated
and you're not taking medications
that could potentially
harm your one kidney
'cause you are at higher risk
for certain medical problems.
Obviously 'cause you don't
have a backup kidney.
"Miracle cure," I already
love the name of this page
'cause we all need a miracle cure.
Doesn't exist but we all need one.
"Try these sleeping positions
to improve your health."
Well why does it say "try
these sleeping positions,"
when it says two out of
three those are wrong,
and only one of them is right?
I don't like that sleeping
position that much.
I mean for certain people
it might be comfortable.
Keeping your arms like that,
elevated above your head,
can really cause some impingement issues,
especially around your rotator cuff.
Your rotator cuff is made of four muscles
that attach to your shoulder,
really give it fine motor control.
This is the infraspinatus, supraspinatus,
teres minor and subscapularis,
sometimes that one gets stuck in my head.
When you have them in this position,
that can sometimes put pressure
there, decrease circulation.
You wake up sort of with a dead arm,
so I'm not a huge fan of that position.
Laying on the side is fine,
laying on the back is fine,
if you have the right pillow
and mattress combination.
Ideally you want to
have a firm enough bed,
where you have support,
so you're back doesn't
completely collapse,
but not so firm that
it puts pressure on you
as a side-sleeper into your shoulder
'cause that could also
be quite uncomfortable.
A little pro tip here.
Depending on how much you weigh,
will also play a role in the firmness
that you experience from a mattress.
If I, as someone who is 200 plus pounds
lay on a medium mattress,
I may find it too soft 'cause I'm heavier
than if let's say my sister,
who's like 120 pounds lays
on that same mattress.
So always test them out
if you have the option.
"Seven things about your tongue color
"can reveal about your health.
"Stick out your tongue for
a quick health check-up."
Before we start, know that these videos
are almost never accurate
because there is
variations to human color,
variations to organs
and there could be normal
anatomical variations
that this thing can't
take into consideration.
So it's bound to make
huge generalizations,
which end up inaccurate,
but let's see how inaccurate.
Light pink, "You are healthy,"
and they painted the tongue the
color of a neon highlighter.
If your tongue is the color
of a pink neon highlighter,
you're a cartoon 'cause
I don't think I've ever
seen that in a human body.
Whoa, what a jump from pink.
If your tongue is red,
"You might be suffering
from an infectious disease."
This is the definition
of healthcare associated,
health information associated anxiety.
This where we always make the joke,
you go on WebMD, you
find out you have cancer,
this is the problem.
The fact that this says,
"Your tongue is red,
"it means you have an infectious disease,"
this would scare the life out of me.
If your tongue is a color that
you're not used to seeing,
talk to your doctor about it.
Do not assume you have
an infelicitous disease
'cause honestly I look at my tongue
and say that it is red right now,
and I don't have an
infectious disease, I promise.
"This is why beer is healthy."
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
"Beer increases bone density.
"Beer has a high concentration of silicon,
"which helps to bind muscle
and bone tissue together
"and increases bone mass."
Not 100% certain about silicon whether
it helps bind muscle and
bone tissue together,
but I will say that
whatever ingredient in beer
helps you have strong bones,
can most definitely be
gotten from other sources
without the need for alcohol.
So already I'm gonna say this is poo poo!
"Moderate beer consumption lowers
"your risk of heat attack
by 25 to 40," lies!
They probably found an
awful, poor quality,
uncontrolled study and they're trying
to draw conclusions from it.
This is absolutely not true.
In fact, the studies that
we've used in the past
to say that there is some
benefit to drinking alcohols,
usually came from studies
related to wine consumption, not beer.
In fact, heavy drinking increases
the risk of heart disease.
Alcohol is actually cardiotoxic
to the chambers of your heart,
the muscles of your heart.
It could actually cause
dilated cardiomyopathy,
where your heart becomes so enlarged
that it's floppy and doesn't work well
in pumping blood throughout your body.
"Enjoying a beer also
helps increase the amount
"of healthy HDL cholesterol in your body."
(sighs)
No, it does not lower
your cholesterol level.
Drinking beer often will
increase your cholesterol level
overall and cause more problems
leading to plaque formation,
which is why having a
high cholesterol is worse.
So no, beer is not a solution
for any of these problems thus far.
Whenever I give advice about alcohol,
my advice is always, "If you
don't need it, don't use it
"because there's no real
proven benefit from it."
If you do use it, make sure you use it
in a smallest amounts possible
so that if there is a potential benefit,
you're maximizing that
and minimizing the harms.
"Top nine benefits of grounding,"
oh this is my Mercola.
"Did you know that the
energy from the Earth
"can help you live a healthier life?"
Yeah, like if you go out into the sun,
your body can create Vitamin D.
"Improves sleep quality and promotes
"feelings of restfulness upon waking."
Now I know this whole time,
my patients have been
struggling with sleep,
I should've just told
them to go out for a walk
on grass without their shoes on.
"Reduce muscle stiffness and soreness."
I mean these claims are just ridiculous.
At least give me how that could happen.
Like are you gonna make a stretch
and say there's an electrical charge
leaving my body and it
becomes one with the Earth,
and that makes my muscles relax?
Like come on.
Like we have to be reasonable.
I'm gonna summarize this
video for you without lying.
This is the honest version of this video.
Hey, go outside and go
for a walk in nature,
and I guarantee you because you're happy,
because you're less stressed,
you're breathing fresh air,
you're seeing green all around you,
which is actually more
pleasing to the eye,
you're gonna feel more relaxed.
You're gonna have better
health outcomes overall.
You can keep your shoes
on or take them off,
whatever's most comfortable to you,
and I don't need to promise you anything
'cause overall it's a healthy thing.
Ooh, "The Best Hangover Cure."
Just so you know, a hangover
is usually oversimplified
when we think about it.
A hangover is this all
sort of different symptoms
and simultaneous things are
happening within your body.
Dehydration, alcohol
intoxication, diarrhea, nausea,
gastritis in the stomach,
all these things are
happening simultaneously.
So a hangover is really a
combination, a confluence,
of symptoms if you will.
"If anyone knows how to cure a hangover,
"it would be a chef."
No.
If anyone would know
how to cure a hangover,
it would be a scientist.
Two ingredients.
Ice.
Two parts Fernet and one part what?
My man solution to hangover
is to drink more alcohol.
Yeah, if you're having alcohol withdrawal,
it will ease your withdrawal symptoms,
but that is not a cure by any means.
"Tastes like a minty pinecone."
You know what, sometimes I
do wake up in the morning
and I'm like, "I wish I had a
"minty pinecone taste
in my mouth right now."
How is that pleasurable.
"Breaking: Courts discreetly confirm
"MMR vaccine causes," no.
It doesn't.
And that's not what the court confirmed.
In fact, just today, there was
a medical article published
from The Journal of American
Medical Association,
they looked at five countries,
2,000,000 participants,
they found 22,000 of them who
were diagnosed with autism,
which is one in 90,
and they found that 80% of the
autism cases were inherited.
That means not due to
vaccinations or anything external.
That's so important to talk about
'cause those who are anti-vaccine
will hijack some of this misinformation
and try to convince you their points
to scare you away from
vaccines unnecessarily.
This is about the truth
and if we're trying to do
the best for our patients,
we can't just go off of unproven
hypotheses and theories,
we need to look at the evidence,
and there's been a study
of 600,000 children
who've been vaccinated,
no link with autism found.
This study with millions of people
finding that autism, 80% of
the time is mainly inherited,
these are important things to look at.
Please do not fall for the misinformation
that comes from a lot of these
"natural" sources on Facebook.
This is probably the worst form
of misinformation on Facebook.
Check out these hilarious TikToks,
or this awesome video I do
with my nephews recently.
We also gotta give a
huge thank you once again
to Thrive Market for
sponsoring this video.
I just placed my order and
I can't wait to get it,
you should too, link's down below.
Stay happy and healthy.
(lively music)